hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal das sich voll und
ganz um die app trading drehen wird
falls du dich kennen solltet lebt er
wahrscheinlich hinterm mond also kurz
zusammengefasst bei legt ein foto von
sich oder einem freund oder von
irgendwem anders hoch und die app sagt
einem dann hey du siehst quasi genau so
aus wie diese berühmtheit und das haben
wir auf grund dieser entwicklung dieser
vier bilder jetzt festgestellt und ich
habe 15 bilder von youtube draußen so
kann ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt
an das hier ist das erste foto das ich
vorbereitet habe und zwar es ist ein
ganz einfaches spiegelzelt die von mir
selbst also ich würde sagen ich klicke
jetzt einfach mal in der app darauf dass
sie da war dass ich sie gar nicht aus
wie mesut özil aber gerade für solche
fälle also wenn wir uns beispielsweise
einfach denken das kommt überhaupt nicht
hin können wir ganz einfach auf der
erneut laden klicken und wir sehen schon
als zweites bild sehe ich aus wie keith
haring
ich weiß nicht verkehrt herum nicht noch
mal drauf und da sich ab
[Musik]
die eppsteiner altstadt doch nicht so
gut zu funktionieren würde ich sagen
machen wir direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten photons was ist das hier das
ist rieso und auch bei wiso würde ich
sagen will ich das einfach mal aus und
an alle unter euch die jf dieses nicht
kennen ist der gründer von amazon und
der reichste mann der welt
also ich habe mir eigentlich gedacht
dass wir anderes warum kommt weil allein
von den haaren passt überhaupt nicht
aber ich dachte das ist bei wie so
spannend weil er halt blaue haare hat
die nächste person ist cameron dallas
ich drücke noch ein letztes mal auf
erneut laden und wir sehen dass hier
stephen hawking aus also drei personen
die komplett unterschiedlichen alters
sind und komplett unterschiedlich
aussehen aber die app seiten immer dass
die person aus wie wir es so gut machen
wir weiter mit dem nächsten youtuber und
zwar für die pan meine damen und herren
der youtuber mit den meisten abonnenten
der welt sieht so aus wie ivan rakitic
also viele leute unter euch werden
ivan rakitic wahrscheinlich nicht kennen
der als fußballer beim fc barcelona ich
finde er sieht nicht so aus deswegen
klicke ich einfach mal auf erneut laden
und wir sehen es ich dachte es kommt
eben raus aber es ist wahr dass das
kommt natürlich auch sagen allerdings
klingen wir noch ein letztes mal auf
erneut laden und sehen die dritte person
die aussieht wie er als gustavo lima
denn ich auch nicht kommen wir klicken
noch mal drauf dann haben wir haben eine
frau scarlett johannsson ja die app ist
noch ausbaufähig ich habe in den letzten
tagen beziehungsweise wochen einfach
unfassbar viele nachrichten artikel
bilder allgemeinen et cetera pp zu
dieser abgesehen hat mir gerade dazu
muss ich unbedingt ein video hochladen
von daher würde ich sagen machen direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten youtuber es ist
simon will und ich lade auch simon
willen die app hoch und
dass das geht ja das ist ja komplett
daneben simon hat einfach rote haare und
es hellhäutig und es kommt dabei raus
paul pogba der einfach dunkelhäutig ist
und kurze schwarze haare pop bar ist
übrigens fußballspieler falls ihn jemand
nicht kennen sollte allerdings können
klicken einfach wieder hier auf erneut
laden und sehen als nächste personen
lewis hamilton
der ist auch dunkelhäutig ich klicke mal
noch mal drauf und es kommt es kommt
margaret thatcher die mich allerdings
kommen wir nun zur ersten frau die ich
vorbereitet habe und zwar ist es hat ja
gerade witz ja meine lieblings youtube
sieht aus wie ich kenne auch nicht kelly
ich muss allerdings sagen dass ich
überhaupt nicht in dieser stars und
sternchen welt irgendwo unterwegs wird
deswegen klicke ich einfach mal wieder
auf erneut laden und als nächste
personen sehen wir jessica es kann da
bin ich jetzt auch nicht so gleich aus
und die letzte person ist amy winehouse
ja wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
youtuber julien wenn meine lieben
freunde sieht so aus wie kim nam union
weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr her ist es
sehr sehr bei bts oder so tue ich mich
gerade bitte hätte bin ich dafür ich
denke auf jeden fall wieder auf erneut
laden und die nächste person ist haruki
murakami ok und die letzte person was
die app vermutet ist winzer den kenn ich
wirklich nicht ja aber ich würde sagen
die wahl eigentlich alle gar nicht mal
so weit davon entfernt die nächste
person die ich vorbereitet habe seht ihr
hier schon eingeblendet und zwar ist das
region
[Musik]
wie maria scharapowa die tennisspielerin
soweit ich da richtig beziehen wir das
vielleicht auch falsch ich glaube ich
glaube die tennisspielerin ich denke
allerdings wieder auf erneut laden und
auf dem nächsten bild sind also ich weiß
nicht wo die app dabei wie weibliche
züge sid ich sehe die jetzt nicht so
allerdings werde ich wieder auf erneut
laden und als setzen wir haben lisa
kudrow wer auch immer das ist keine
ahnung aber reh wurde dreimal mit einer
frau verglichen da gebe ich meine lieben
freunde ist die nächste youtube in die
nhl besteht überhaupt keine ähnlichkeit
also stieg direkt darauf erneut laden
ob wir was besseres finden das könnte
wirklich sein gerade wenn man sich das
immer sich das bild oben links anschauen
also dass ausgangs foto von dhabi und
dann das ein foto von sea shepherd
könnte es auf jeden fall sei nichtig
allerdings normal auf erneut laden und
da haben wir katie holmes
wir werden allerdings besser wenn auch
mit kleinen schritten und wo wir schon
katja hatten und jetzt auch gerade da
geht meine lieben freunde darf natürlich
auch babys beauty palace nicht fehlen
sie sieht aus wie lisa kudrow auch
wurde rivenich auch schon gesagt dass
das reh wieder da bitten also hier
besteht auf jeden fall eine sehr
deutliche ähnlichkeit finde ich gerade
wenn man sich wieder ausgangs foto von
baby und das and photo und rechts von
dieser chor anguckt dann täglich
allerdings wieder auf erneut laden und
jahren hätte ich jetzt nicht mehr das
ist nochmal claudia leid weil es ja auch
nicht wer das ist
ich glaube einfach dass sich diese app
daran orientiert hey welche haarfarbe
hatten nie das macht auch keinen sinn
weil bei simon will der hat rote haare
und dann kam schwarzarbeit die fresse du
leben als nächsten youtuber habe ich
mich ihr team vom kanal gewitter im kopf
rausgesucht wenn ich ihn ja aus wieder
gut
[Musik]
weiter voneinander entfernen können zwei
personen glaube ich nicht sein und dann
klicke ich einfach mal wieder auf
erneute laden und als nächste person
habe ich ja einfach wie ob samuel
jackson
ok ich krieg wieder auf erneut laden
wenn er jetzt noch mal kommt der werden
durchsagen nehmen wir als nächstes jahr
vom kanal gewitter im kopf
ok rory mcilroy wenn ich jetzt auch
nicht ich hätte ein besen gefressen und
wieder samuel jackson rausgekommen wäre
ein paar sekunden später das sind zwei
komplett unterschiedliche personen die
leute wieder auf erneut laden wenn jetzt
noch mal stanley jackson
[Musik]
doch hielt aber an alle leute und sascha
ist der nächste youtuber den ich
vorbereitet habe und er sieht aus wie
lewis hamilton auch das ist der wahnsinn
dabei ist er aber im umkehrschluss dass
simon wohl genauso aussieht wie sascha
das sehe ich jetzt nicht so ganz wichtig
allerdings wieder auf erneut laden und
als nächste person haben wir eddie
murphy besteht jetzt gar keine
ähnlichkeit lewis hamilton konnte ich
mich noch irgendwie erklären jetzt haben
wir de france die touchdowns ist glaube
ich sängerin ich meine vergleicht
einfach wieder das ausgangs foto mit dem
wir besteht 0,0 ähnlichkeit simon
ungespielt ist der nächste youtuber den
ich vorbereitet habe und wer
wer steven seagal kenn ich nicht ich
klicke auf erneut laden und wir haben
tom hardy
[Musik]
tom hardy ist aber auch egal ich gehe
wieder auf erneut laden und als nächstes
haben wie carrie fisher
also ich finde gerade mit dem bart kann
man männlicher nicht aussehen auf dem
ersten foto deswegen checke ich nicht
wie die sich dieser app dann denkt er
simon gespielt da sie auf wie carrie
fisher und es ist der vorletzte youtuber
den ich vorbereitet habe für das heutige
video wiz khalifa es kommt sogar hin
ich glaube einfach mittlerweile dass
sich die es gar nicht so krass am
aussehen orientiert sondern nur an den
gesichtszügen
weil also gerade wenn man auch hier
wieder ausgangs foto und das letzte foto
dann vom burj khalifa vergleicht ist
halt der gesichts zug einfach genau
gleich wichtig allerdings wieder auf
erneut laden und wir haben hier sechs
mein gott das ist sehr krass da besteht
wirklich eine ähnlichkeit besteht
allerdings wieder auf erneut laden und
wir haben daniel alves auch
fußballspieler hat früher glaube ich
gespielt bei auch beim fc barcelona als
teil des teams bisher auf jeden fall mit
das krasseste finde ich allerdings gehen
wir nun für den letzten utah in den
amerikanischen raum und zwar ist es
mister biest er rasiert die youtube
sehen ja gerade wie kein anderer und er
sieht
ich weiß auch hier wieder durchweg xenia
sobtschak ist aber wichtig auf erneut
laden und wir haben hält sie also eine
sängerin also zweimal wurde minister
wies verglichen mit promis und zweimal
wurde er weiblich eingestuft und setzte
personen haben wir wieder eine frauen
fast 11 london also die app muss nochmal
deutlich überarbeitet werden an der
stelle sich das heutige video ist
allerdings trotzdem erst mal beenden
meine lieben freunde sehr viele von euch
an unter meiner letzten videos
geschrieben hey luca das ja schon so
videos gemacht auf den webseiten
house.net und so weiter und so fort
macht das doch auch mal mit gradient da
könntest ja auch ein paar youtube
auswählen und einfach schauen wie die
dann nicht vom hort haid grad werden
falls es das wort übergeben sollte
bewertet werden sollen was halt einfach
deren promi doppelgänger sind und das
hat in vielen fällen nicht geklappt
heute wenn euch das video trotzdem
gefallen da würde ich mich sehr darüber
einen daumen hoch freund schreibt auf
jeden fall kehren und in die kommentare
was ich morgen hochladen soll das dürft
ihr dann bestimmen der kommentar kommt
dann ins morgige video und jetzt das
[Musik]